[Music]  it was great the other night with Keith  we bet nicole kidman would say that  again about her PDA filled night out  with hubby Keith Urban in New York City  the big little lies star stepped out  with her husband Tuesday to honor  HBO chairman and CEO Richard cleaver at  the annual American Songbook gala I've  got a lot of support an enormous amount  of support from my husband 50 year-old  Nicole brought a little practical magic  to the night glittering in a Golgi bocce  gown and things only got more magical  when she joined her man on stage for a  steamy smooch it's clear Nicole and he'd  had no problem putting their love on  display here they are locking lips in a  passionate kiss at the ceremony kind of  like nice right nice indeed the power  couple has seemingly figured out how to  balance career and marriage perfectly if  you have passion and love for what you  do  then that will power you carry you  through anything  [Music]  [Applause]